I was uninsured less than a year ago I
was uninsured seven months ago and and
so I want folks to raise your hand again
because I know what being uninsured is
like it's not just a financial issue it
is the stress and it is the anxiety when
you wake up every morning and you don't
know if you're gonna slip on a curb if
you're going to find something on your
body that you want to get checked out if
your knee starts to ache everything
becomes a spiral of anxiety because you
don't know how you're going to afford it
so when we talk about rationing care in
a for-profit health care system with no
guardrails where it's the Wild West
where you're allowed to profiteer off of
insulin off of people's lives how many
of you in your time of uninsured or
having health care that was too
expensive delayed getting a prescription
or delayed going to the doctor delayed
going to the doctor
so you rationed your own care is that
correct miss Burton yes absolutely the
cost of a for-profit insurance company
forced you to ration your own care
correct absolutely I know exactly what
that's like i rationed my own health
care for ten years I was on a
self-imposed waitlist
for ten years not going to an
orthopedist where my knee hurt not going
to seek mental health care or counseling
when my father died all of those things
this right here is a complete complete
condemnation of the for-profit health
care insurance industry because while
they're talking about how socialized
medicine how how a public guaranteed to
the right to healthcare will force us to
ration care
we are rationing our own care we're not
talking about months long waiting lists
under the system we have now we're
talking about years long waiting lists
for the system that we have now